the 18th century you start to have
significant interaction between the
English and the Indians especially in
the East India Company and as part of
that you start to have Western scholars
start to really study Sanskrit and the
Vedas and as they do this it starts to
really open up their mind not just to
the roots of Sanskrit but also many of
the Western languages including English
itself so this is a quote in 1786 by the
English philology someone who studies
written language especially from
historical sources Sir William Jones he
wrote the Sanskrit language
whatever be its antiquity is a wonderful
structure more perfect than the Greek
more copious than the Latin and more
exquisitely refined than either yet
bearing to both of them a stronger
affinity both in the roots of the verbs
and in the forms of grammar then could
not possibly have been produced by
accident let me underline that then
cannot possibly have been produced by
action so he says it's a lot of
commonality between the Sanskrit and
Latin and Greek and it's a strong
affinity a strong connectedness that
could not have been produced by
accidents so strong indeed that no
philology could examine all three
without believing them to have sprung
from some common source let me underline
that without believing them to have
sprung from some common source which
perhaps no longer exists
there's a similar reason though not
quite so forcible for supposing that
both the Gothic and the Celtic though
blended with a very different idiom had
the same origin with the Sanskrit and
the Old Persian might be added to the
same family and so when they started to
study the Vedas look at Sanskrit they
started as well maybe all of these
languages are connected and now
modern-day Falah lodgest believe this
very strongly the more that they have
studied it they based on the connections
in the grammar and even the vocabulary
and the word structure themselves they
now theorize that a parent language of
Sanskrit Latin and the Germanic
languages and the Celtic languages we
call a language today called
proto-indo-european which is a lost
language but we think that Sanskrit is
one of the oldest
is one of the oldest evidences that we
have of that proto-indo-european
language Sanskrit is of course the
parent language has evolved in different
parts of India into languages like Hindi
Bengali and Punjabi Latin which is also
a dead language now has evolved into
languages like Spanish Italian and
French and English which is considered a
Germanic language structurally but has
significant influence from Latin and
French they all come from that same
proto indo-european root and just to get
an appreciation for why these falala
gist believe this and this is something
when I first saw it really blew my mind
a little bit I'll show you some
connections between Sanskrit words and
those of you who might be Hindi Bengali
or Punjabi speakers or any of these
North Indian languages in India we'll
see the connection to Sanskrit but
what's amazing is how these words are
connected to Latin and many of those
languages derived from Latin some of you
Persian speakers might recognize some
some commonalities and most importantly
the language we're speaking right now
how it's related to English and so
here's just a sample of some Sanskrit
words that have an eerie resemblance to
both English and in some cases Latin
words or in many cases Latin words I've
just given Latin in a few of them so the
scratch Sanskrit mater well in English
we have mother and in Latin we have
mater and we also from Latin in English
via Latin we have words like maternity
and maternal all referring to the same
idea of motherhood and this general
trend this T sound mater or mater
becoming more of a dust sound in English
in the Germanic languages of trend
you'll see over and over again in
Sanskrit you have bitter in Latin you
have Potter and lat by way of Latin in
modern English we have words like
paternity and paternal but going through
the Germanic languages you have once
again that the sound becoming more of a
buzz sound and you also see this pattern
as you go from this proto-indo-european
this theoretical language and especially
if you think about relative to Sanskrit
that you you have this sound going from
a
to a Fah as you go to the Germanic
languages so Pitzer becomes you could
say father
in other words na in Sanskrit and those
of you who speak Hindi or Bengali would
recognize that of course and in English
it is no Gao which is still it's a Hindi
word for cow in English its cow cow cow
nama name in Latin Norman dois door this
one I thought was really interesting I
didn't know this until I started looking
it up a little bit Anamika is Sanskrit
and it means anonymous call which is
referring to time in Sanskrit and in
modern Sanskrit Drive languages like
Hindi and Bengali it's referring to
references in time tomorrow yesterday
and in English you have calendar Naz and
in something like in modern English's in
the subcontinent have knock and in
English you have nose look in in English
you have the prefix Lok as in location
or locate and then this is of course a
very nice one
Sanskrit love which means desire well in
English we have the word love and this
is just a sample I encourage you to look
it up more you'll be amazed by the
connections between Sanskrit and English
and now I'm going to show you what I
think is one of the coolest because it
isn't just a linguistic connection but
it is also a I guess you could say a
spiritual connection and this is the
names for the sky God from several
different traditions so in the Vedas
they make reference to a God
Theo Spitzer and literally referring to
in BIOS it's referring to sky and we
already talked about Hitler being the
word for father
so it's referring to this idea of a sky
father and some of you might be getting
goosebumps now when you see where this
is going well in Greek we have a very
similar word it's sort of DOS we have
Zeus and those are very similar words
the spelling might be different but the
way it comes out of your mouth is very
similar doubts or doubts
Zuse instead of bitter you have father
once again you have sky you have sky
father sky father right over here and
this is another connection that blew my
mind it wasn't obvious when I first saw
it but Jupiter from Latin the Roman God
you could use you quitter this is once
again instead of duce
you've Jew instead of bit there you have
bitter so instead of dose bitter you
have Jupiter Jupiter Jupiter these are
very very similar words even though the
spelling seems different the way it
comes out of your mouth is very very
very very very close and this is further
evidence for the closeness between
sanskrit between greek and between latin
so once again we have sky father and
this is of course an image of well it's
hard to tell whether that's Jupiter or
Zeus I believe this picture of Jupiter
and what's also interesting is the Vedas
cite juice bitter as the father of Indra
who's considered the king of the gods
one of the most significant if not the
most significant God in Hinduism and
Indra is now in especially in the Vedas
and this is the most spoken about God in
the Vedas it has many of the qualities
that we now in Greek and Roman
traditions associate with Zeus and
Jupiter Indra is the sky God throws
bolts of lightning actually eerie
similarities with the Nordic God of Thor
where and Nordic people were also
indo-european people where Indra he
throws a hammer and he defeats these
monsters and all these things very
similar to the floor
so hopefully this you know when I first
learned this this just kind of made me
realize how connected the world is and
it started to make me start to look for
patterns where I hadn't seen him before
it really shows how these these
civilizations that seemed very
unconnected might have and probably we
do believe emerged in emerged from the
same place modern follow just and and
historians believe that this
proto-indo-european might have been
spoken by people in the caucuses the
word Caucasian is referring really to
people from that Caucasus area there but
we don't know for sure and we believe
that they migrated out and so when we
talk about the Germanic tribes going
into northern Europe the Celtic tribes
going into I guess you could say
north-south Central Europe you could
talk about the italic the Latin tribes
you could talk about the Greek tribes
and you could also talk about the in you
could also talk about the indo-aryan
tribes which eventually would settle
into Persia and into northern India
these we believe are all connected